Bob joins us from somewhere in Rio
actually where are you this morning bomb
I'm somewhere in Rio oh okay under sales
location I'm over I'm I'm overlooking
the Olympic Stadium and the
International broadcast Center where you
will spend part of your time but
actually you and I are not exactly in
the same location throughout the the
Olympics your posted in one place and
I'm in another but I imagine that our
paths will cross at some point give me
some good news about the Olympics it
feels like everything we've read heard
as negative doom and gloom well
everywhere you look this place is a
picture postcard uh it's some of the
most picturesque landscape that you'll
find anywhere uh is it blighted
especially in the waters by sanitation
problems are there favelas that make
what we consider poverty in the United
States seem opulent yes but there are
also soaring structures beautiful
mountain escapes beautiful waterways all
that plus the world's greatest athletes
are bound for real and many of them are
going to do miraculous and wonderful
things and we just have our fingers
crossed that the array of problems that
everyone's aware of don't intrude upon
what we came here primarily to document
which is this great competition do you
think that heightens TV awareness
because of everything that people have
read and heard about it with the Zika
virus or what goes on or you know how
bad the water is there the the Russian
you know athletes being able to come
does that help do you think in
viewership it yeah in an odd way I think
there are people that tune in to see
whether or not they can pull it off to
see if there's some kind of a disaster
but I think the primary thing that will
help the ratings is if there's only a
one hour time difference between rio and
the eastern part of the United States
which means that a good portion of what
we show can be shown live but here I
think it's a misunderstanding about the
Olympics for you
think about it the Olympics is a little
bit like going to the circus there are
multiple events going on simultaneously
so even if you wanted to show everything
live couldn't some of them has to be at
least on a little bit of a delay unless
you broke the screen into about eight
different segments there are things
going on that overlap so some of it will
be able to show you primary stuff
swimming the premier events of track and
field a lot of that stuff gymnastics a
lot of that will be able to show live
but it's impossible to fill everything
live in prime time will it be somewhere
either screaming or on one of the many
NBC platforms including nbcsn where
people are watching you right now we'll
just about everything de live somewhere
yes but not everything can be live in
prime time at the same what amount of
prep have you done for the Olympics I
read a couple newspapers difficult uh
shows and you know what I'll just wing
it what the heck yeah look what could
possibly go wrong yeah you could wing it
it might be interesting now maybe I'll
just what yeah I just do a Howard deal
like in in network for those who are old
enough to remember I'll just fling open
the window just say you know but I don't
care anymore let the chips fall where
they may Al Michaels gave me great
advice he said take it in half hour
increments when you're hosting that know
what you need to know when you need to
know it because the enormity of it
there's so much in understanding all the
venues pronunciations the events
everything that it can be kind of
mind-blowing if you're trying to
compartmentalize all of that is that a
fair assessment of how you go about it
yeah ow hours right and I would add to
that a couple of things our researchers
and for me that goes back to 1988 and
soul researchers have always been
extraordinarily hard working well
informed very very bright and so you
could always rely on them and now it's
better than ever with the digital
revolution any
might not be on your radar screen can be
your fingertips in a moment and all of
us whether it's you or a loved me who've
been at this for a while if we're good
at anything at all it ought to be taking
a briefing making sense of something in
a short period of time put it in some
kind of context and then be able to
express it on the other thing that I've
learned from hosting so many of these
Olympics is that it's almost as
important to be aware of what you don't
need to know you don't need to know
every swimmer from Peru where every
platform divert from Bolivia it's
impossible anyway with more than 10,000
international athletes this isn't a
memory contest you need to know the big
picture and especially the primetime
holes in this case me has to have a good
sense of the history of the Olympics a
good sense of the issues and in this
case there are more issues than at the
usual Olympics the geopolitics of it you
have that a good sense of that some
sense of context and perspective and
then you need to know a couple of dozen
athletes and events that are likely to
make it onto prime time and then it's
something that's outside that
preparation comes up that's what the
researchers are therefore is Bob Costas
joining us from Rio but then Seacrest
gets the swimsuit models the supermodels
there on his show how did that come
about um there was a lottery and
inexplicably he and the setting of
copacabana beach came out on top i think
i think there's a possible conspiracy
then where there were some balls
bouncing around yes there are in the
lottery machine like in the NBA trap and
it came up Seacrest and later we did an
investigation and out of the Dozen
ping-pong balls 11 of them had RC
written on and that stood not for Robert
Costas but for Ryan RS I can't even get
my outfit i select i might almost be 11
I thought I had a joke and I realized I
was alphabetically out of water don't
worry by a week from tonight I'll be
totally coherent nothing to worry about
uh you have a favorite sport you know
I'm kind of old-school when it comes to
this
track and field to me at the Summer
Olympics the the track events are the
most classic events a better course
swimming has moved way up there it
always was one of the premier Olympic
events and now in the Phelps era even
more so gymnastics it could very well
happen that when we leave Rio will be
able to say including people who really
know the history of gymnastics and our
expert about it are able to say that
Simone biles of the United States has
delivered the greatest performance of
any female gymnast in the history of the
olympics and Kohei Uchimura of japan is
the greatest male gymnasts in the
history of the olympics now that's it it
all toss out for them and they bring
their a-game and everything falls into
place but that's entirely possible so
you know those those events the
gymnastics was swimming and the big
events are track and field Usain Bolt
the decathlon that kind of thing so
those are the ones that generally draw
my attention I will see in a couple days
there Bob thanks for joining us you got
it travel safe see the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience